[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hi I know you're nervous I just want to
have a chat
I'm seeing something no one else can see
except for me it's smiling at me
yesterday a patient in your care died
brutally in front of you
[Music]
I need to find an explanation for what
happened oh
smiling at me
smiling at me
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
I found 20 cases involving 19 victims
with a direct line linking them all
together
[Applause]
you said only 19.
why is it that everybody else who's seen
it just dead in your life
seen it too
yeah
[Music]
how long between each victim's death
none of them survived longer than a week
today is my fourth day I am not gonna
keep running
face it how does that make you feel
[Music]
thank you
I'm just really scared that something
bad is going to happen
[Applause]
[Music]
it's been four years
since Michael Myers vanished Without a
Trace
[Music]
hello
[Music]
I was certain that I saw him
watching me
you pretend like you moved on but you're
actually just obsessed with death what
are you gonna do when Michael comes back
for you because he is coming
but this time
something feels different
he's more dangerous
foreign
[Music]
he killed my daughter but tonight I will
kill him come and get me
boys
[Music]
maybe the only way he can die is if I
die too it all ends now
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I know it's unusual in this day and age
to devote your life to something
spiritual hey good morning but ever
since my mother's issues I've always
felt a calling to help people
foreign
[Music]
she's not as scary as she looks she can
hear you
you're my favorite person here us girls
we gotta stick together in this place
we have a female student in the class
only as an observer because as you know
women are strictly forbidden from
performing exorcism female surgeons are
once Unthinkable somebody had to be the
first
when you enter the room of the possessed
you are walking onto a Battlefield
strike Terror lured into the Beast now
defiling this innocent child
I can't hear you no
[Music]
I'm here
with you
yes
you have a gift I'd like to teach you
this relationship it's personal we all
have a personal relationship with God
this feeling has followed me my entire
life
you got my invitation
we've been waiting for you
[Music]
foreign
right yeah I'm renting this place no I
booked it a month ago are you sure you
have the right place yeah who am I
supposed to do
why don't you come inside and we'll call
these idiots
[Music]
why don't you just crash here oh no
I don't know if you've got a great look
at this neighborhood but I don't think
you should be out there by yourself
it's drying there's a lock on the door
by the way I'm Keith Tess
you take the bedroom and I'll sleep out
here on the couch
[Music]
kiss
ES
Keith
[Music]
foreign
this process might seem overwhelming
but with a little practice
it can soon become
a pleasurable experience
this is Perfectly Natural
foreign
[Music]
the
creeper comes back every 23 years then
what
[Music]
I believe I let you drag me
this is the Coachella of Cosplay
time four
three birds
a grand prize
an escape room for two
creep a thing come on YouTube
are you sure this is where we're
supposed to be
we'll be out there in no time
[Music]
Keepers baby what the hell is that
it's coming
it's a trap let's go
there's no way out
come on
foreign
[Music]
are you okay
[Music]
I had an overdose
come home I could look after you
everything here is just like old times
you're the first person I've seen who
actually looks like they've got any
older since I left
doesn't anyone die around here
I knew I recognized you
your mother she's very popular in the
village
[Applause]
mum oh I've missed that word
say it again
this isn't how I remember it things
change you haven't
I'll never hurt you
remember when you threatened to take my
mouth shut
I want to try to get past the past
of course
[Music]
your mom asked me to wait sure you
didn't leave
nothing up there something against God
something
to another and change the village
[Music]
what's happening to me
I just wanted you to be
[Applause]
[Music]
do you girls believe in Paranormal
Activity
Spirits
a demonologist
no I don't well I do because I'm gonna
be playing one
they want you back in for a call back on
Monday yes
I need this roll
I saw your ad
[Music]
s
I need you to trust me there can be no
lies or the ritual will have very little
chance of success
ritual
[Laughter]
an exorcism
it's a human blood shall we get started
David's coming in any forms
I need to be great or else they're gonna
give the role to Donald
Trump told me you already had this car
like that
was a lie
you're scared I'm not scared
are you out of your mind
what are you hiding from
how do I get out of here
I've been waiting for you my whole night
[Music]
beautiful isn't it
it's really nice
you can hold it
what is it
it's a puzzle
[Applause]
and it's almost finished
keep going
so if I solve it
do I get a prize
I do
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
six configurations
it opens up
and it cuts you
[Applause]
and then they come to collect
it's it's time
greater Delights await
eat it
their blood
their pain
for us
I want to see you pray for
it was always just my mom and me to have
a family that's what I really want
no way I got a cousin that is the
whitest man I've ever seen he wants to
meet up Oliver cousin Evie it sounds so
Jane Austen when you say it like that
you know my mom always wanted to take me
to England to learn about her family
history for this wedding coming up
actually you should come I would love to
but come on everyone is dying to meet
you
[Music]
wow it's incredible
I believe this is one of our important
guests Evie this is a close friend of
the family Walter DeVille uh hi hi
looking forward to getting to know you
better
[Music]
what are you doing down there
miss you should return to your room
we're all so delighted that you're here
which ones have we grow the groom and
his friends who make their grand
entrance tomorrow
ready
I can't shake the feeling that everyone
is staring at me
you and Walter seem to be getting off
too close to me
I'm curious though what if I told you
about us
let me see
there she is where are the bride and
groom
as you all know there has been someone
missing from this table but that one's
broken bond will be renewed tonight
a new Pride
I want to go home but this is your home
get up in bed
help me please
here dear hello Mr Harker here there's a
young lady who seems quite distressed
I'm so glad you've come to your senses
my love
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
but when the fear begins
when the paranoia takes over
it makes people do terrible things
good morning as you can see some of you
have chosen to stay home today given
what's been happening
[Music]
some scary internet character that tells
you to kill people it made this kid stab
his own mother there's a lot of people
freaking out about it nobody knows what
it actually is
you saw the Grim Cutty yeah like in my
house what is it
[Music]
calls about it all night
how are we supposed to protect our
family
my parents can't see it
but when I try to tell them what I saw
it just makes it more hysterical
hey Dad can we start over look we can
just sit down and I'll talk it out
together
I'm just trying to protect him
thank you
hi I'm Annie Hardy and you're watching
band car
Another Day in Paradise
hello listen I just need you to take my
friend somewhere nearby
this is Angela her and I taking a trip
did you find me
ah
[Music]
you should go see if she's alive
hello hello
guys she's here
hey what was that oh my God oh my God oh
my gosh
look again
[Music]
please Lord make me the biggest star the
world has ever known so that'll make it
far far away from this place no caring
for your family during these times is
admirable
to get one ticket this life if only they
would just die
pardon
nothing
[Applause]
I wanna be special dancing up on the
screen let the pretty girls in the
picture
I will not let you leave this Farm again
something real wrong with me rumor has
it they only take one gal or town
we're looking for someone with X Factor
by the film nobody else has seen
will be eventually
I know what I've done
terrible awful murderous things
I want to be loved from as many people
as possible
truth is I'm not really a good person
[Music]
all right all right well I gotta say
that is a very handsome client why
didn't you step me up with him you
deserve someone nice
[Music]
three Ethan
that's me
[Music]
I thought you would appreciate the best
sushi
[Music]
wondering
the only thing that matters now is our
game
I'm gonna ask you
[Music]
you are a marked woman now
he can smell you
[Music]
if you want to survive his game
the only person who can help you is
either
I just need to lay low tonight
how are you surviving now huh
no one beats him he's like a monster
I'm not gonna go anywhere sweetheart
what are you
[Music]
please
coveted rooms
[Music]
I call upon the spirits of this house
to grant us a moment of your time
[Music]
gave her father
41. take my hands at my help
but she dare touch me old [ __ ]
Tara I killed you so I'll kill you again
[Music]
we curse let's just start with seeing Dr
Sanchez tomorrow
I'm not crazy
mid teens is when this disease first
manifests and you can be prone to fits
of anger stop going in my room and
violence
experience multiple personalities
use different voices hear voices
you okay
I do think it's interesting
you don't know anything about that I'm
not gonna let anyone hurt you ever
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
best
you ready Freddy
hello there young lady good afternoon oh
what is this place it's your new home
isn't it wonderful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
I miss you I miss my son well you better
get used to it because you'll never see
either one of us ever again
mother How Could You Scout my number he
just wants to talk why don't I come and
stay with you for a while I don't need
any help everything is perfect
[Music]
mom there's there's a monster outside my
window
you and I are completely safe
like two bugs snug in a rug
I want to go home
foreign
Church
I think I have edema in my house
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
happy dancers the world
[Music]
this place is great
you can fix it up
this is what we wanted welcome home
this is Robert my husband it is so nice
to meet you Robert
yeah I guess I can see a resemblance
they look exactly like me
Robert I know you're new to these parts
[Music]
I speak for everyone when I say you
already feel like one of us
[Music]
say it I was just hoping you might be
able to give me some more information
about it
you're wrong
you know I just found another painting
of him
everyone knows okay listen you don't
actually think that's you
[Music]
something is off
about this place
I swear it's the same guy in every
single one I would just take it as a
sign you uh
you are meant to be
you need to run do you understand me no
go go
foreign
I'll be home in the morning we're going
I'm staying over at Susie's tonight
[Music]
the flyer
the paper's calling the Grabber I wish
you wouldn't call them that you don't
actually believe that story do you
because he can't hear you and he doesn't
really take kids that safe
you need some help you see that
would you give me my hat
sir
hi I'm a part-time magician
are those five balloons in there
would you like to see a magic trick
I have an announcement to make one of
our students Vinnie Blake was abducted
what if I could help the police signed a
penny
[Applause]
[Music]
does it work
not since I was a kid
full screen I'll scratch your face this
face
Daddy I had a dream about it what
happened in your dream he was taken by a
man with black balloons yes we never
released those details
foreign
who are you
you know all our names
you're getting out of here
please please let the dreams be real I
hate the wall in front of you I tore a
long cable loose from down there
I'm the inside of the storm door what's
the combination
curved it in the wall
tree the door the gate I'd never seen it
before it except in my dreams
much time
you're gonna use a weapon you raise the
phone set back and swing
look what you made me do please hurry
you remember what I told you someday I
should stand up for myself someday is
today Finn
[Music]
whoa damn it drew get out of here
okay that is new glad you guys are still
finding ways to spice things up we're
leaving in five okay
these these are the amazing people
keeping the break with group shot
I kind of wanted to save this prize but
whatever I'll tell you guys now it's a
smart house so I'll send you guys the
link
okay let's do this
now you guys are excited told you I'd
come through wow Andrew Collins you go
by Drew right welcome home
I've been designed and programmed to
cater to your every need so she's like
the house or what most people just call
me Marco
kidding me now go explore
[Music]
I have quite the weekend in store for
you
what is this this entire place is one
gigantic 3D printer don't tell me you
can't handle this
hear that
this is something I've been working on
for a long time
I've never seen ai's this Advanced
I mean I can't wait to show you what
else I have in mind
who wants to party
but we gotta reach the climax yet
this is
[Music]
hello hi this is Marlo yes power for yes
dip coming the words I have to say it's
a beautiful house
would it just be you staying
excuse me Mrs mother no until you give
your love there's nothing more that we
can do happen from the garden yeah it
was delicious
mustn't do that
forbidden fruit oh God sorry oh
you're tormented
it feels more like
haunted yeah
something happened
husband went upstairs to our balcony and
let himself go
you must wonder why you drove him to it
but I didn't drive into it
I could be true
but if you'd given him the chance to
apologize he'd still be alive what
a man he followed me out of the woods
he was stalking me what makes you say
that I saw him twice twice
I don't know if he saw you once
I wanna play a game you hide I'll see
you
must feel an awful sense
stay away from me
what are you doing
[ __ ] are you
[Music]
we're still trying to figure out what
happened
[Music]
did you last hear from her
[Music]
she left to bring her to school
is everything okay
I should all missing before
not in a long time
[Music]
I heard about your mom is she all right
hey it doesn't feel right
I think we should go away just two of us
I think you should take it easy at the
moment
um where did you go
I'll tell you
not yet
are you awake
what's wrong with you there's things I
need to tell you
it's not your mother up there if we
don't do something we'll never get her
back
and then they'll try to take you
dance with me
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're impressive they're gonna be
obsessed with you
they're not as nihilistic as they look
on the internet you guys this is me
[Music]
this is your first relationship
you just kind of give that Vibe but you
know that has weed in it right
hello
who wants to play body spotty spotted
so how do you play
if you draw the piece of paper that has
the X on it you are the murderer
and if you're the murderer you have to
kill someone by touching them on the
back
the most important part if you come
across a body you have to yell
[Music]
is that the lights
David
our friend is dead
someone's doing this you're trying to
kill us off one by one that'll be so
obvious if I were the killer I couldn't
off my clothes in the windows with the
neighbors
where are you
here
what are you talking about
[Music]
Jordan what are you doing I'm staying
safe really because it looks like we're
grabbing a meat cleaver to go look for
my boyfriend
[Applause]
watch a girl
what happened
I brought something what is it it's
zucchini bread yum oh God
[Music]
a horrible thing happened to you I just
want you to be able to move on with your
life
come here it's coming up on a year I
have something that's planned and I need
a partner in crime the b-67 TV tower I
haven't claimed since Becky if you don't
confront your fears you are always going
to be afraid
let's do it
let's climb your stupid Tower
I'm so excited
[Music]
hey guys
I was really ripped you're awesome that
is the Becky that we need for this trip
this is sick
damn it Andre what are you getting us
into
[Music]
stay behind me one wrong at a time
see it's easy
you're doing great
Becky you gotta come up here
without more
love hey trust me
I'm sure how do we get down
I don't have a signal
the waters out there in that bag we have
50 feet of rope
I think I could drop myself lower
Hunter
every hour the pass is the weaker we get
if anyone called 9-1-1 they'd be here by
now
what is it that Dan used to say if
you're scared of dying don't be afraid
to live
it's a brand new organ
never before seen
what's up we've all felt that the body
was empty
empty of meaning
and we've wanted to confirm that
so that we could fill it with meaning
[Music]
the world is a much more dangerous place
now that pain has all that disappeared
[Music]
that surgery is thanks isn't it is it
do you know what it is
surgery is the new sex
I don't like what's happening with the
body
in particular what's happening with my
body
[Music]
which is why I keep cutting it up
I think they'd find inside him
that is not be afraid to map the chaos
inside
[Music]
let us create them
that will guide us
Into the Heart of Darkness
[Music]
good morning ladies and gentlemen I'm
guessing that some of you you're not
happy maybe you don't fit in people make
fun of you well I can't make you
straight
but you give us this week and we might
be able to help
boys cabin over there girls cabin over
there I usually them pronouns as in they
can't believe they're at this camp
I have zero interest in not being gay
there's no judgments in this room
sometimes our show was invisible
I would understand it a lot more if
there's Bible thumping and queer bashing
do you even believe in any of this
come in please
do you think your parents are
disappointed in you sometimes so what do
you do you try to make yourself
special you become
they
today we're going to be exploring
traditional gender roles
look how long they've been doing this
it's time to play this could get a lot
worse where's my killer we need to get
out of here taste
just enjoy the sunshine and work on your
tan
today slash them streaming only on
peacock August 5th
Tom I know you're trying your best
oh Mariah
spit on it your mom would have been
proud of you but I don't think you'd
feel the same way about the Focus right
now
you ready
this is gonna hurt
what what was that
[Music]
we were just playing slap face
[Music]
what happened
did you see it
walk down a fallen Lane come back here
Pig how far from where you guys are at
Focus sometimes we do terrible things
we can't help ourselves
I'm awakened it's like good witchcraft I
never wonder what he does with himself
everywhere he goes
you don't get it it's something just for
us there's something I gotta know are
you good
or evil
he doesn't eat up the bad kids
she's their friend
[Music]
parties and girls it's gonna be late
[Music]
going to Colombia looks like I got the
looks and the brains of the family
I'm proud of you okay who are you
Governor Finn wants all detained
immigrants gone by election day God I
deported
zero tolerance the D.A is offering to
drop charges if he volunteers to help
Care for senior citizens
an owl Cove we truly appreciate you
being here to help out our seniors
am I supposed to this nasty ass meatloaf
you know because your skin a Argentinian
stick to the program your time here
should be pretty fast and easy
sorry
you really got away with the ladies
what are you talking about you trying to
escape
thank you
it's okay
I promise you you stick with the program
you're going to leave this place more
mature you may even gain a newfound
appreciation for life
Phillips you okay
it's a fellas not breathing
am I in here because I'm Latino or black
or both
what is he doing here we found your
daughter she's alive
be prepared for changes we have a child
therapist that she'll be working with
four years is a long time what she needs
right now is her family mister
sweetheart it's Mommy
welcome home Esther we left it just as
it was
it's lovely to be back I miss my family
very much
our goal here is helping Esther
acclimate back into life within the
family unit
[Music]
sorry
I think something's going on with a stir
is there anything you want to tell me
about your time away
how's that possible four years ago she
was still drawing stick figures
Esther's Behavior has been so erratic
hello Mommy
thank you Mommy
I did notice some inconsistencies
what are you getting at to me it felt
like a performance
if you're not Esther who are you
[Music]
you gotta give Mommy I made it to you
foreign
the mother protects her family
no matter what
that's the story of
that's the Glory of Love
[Music]
yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
last night you made the unfortunate
mistake of breaking into my ancestral
home
don't worry this is not an execution
there's the sword in that good luck
why did let us go why did they wish us
luck
what's that
it's a fox hunt
so what are the hunting
[Music]
people are going to find out about this
about what
we're going to show you Wallflowers the
perks of real flowers
foreign
how bad is it it's not that bad
[Music]
[Applause]
things
follow the heroes not to zero keep up
we need to find weapons if you get us
killed I'm gonna be so pissed what do
you suggest we do I say to draw them to
one side of the building and then slip
through the other
I'm in DND level 20 raw wizard that
protect us
oh
what is it with these shut-ins in Zombie
fantasy when I'm the goddamn comic book
okay whoa watch the Dolce
is he dead
of course he's dead Ryan he just felt
the freaking room
what we need is fire
really dude
[Music]
is it that bad uh more like badass
watch out watch out
everything was perfect
just like I imagined
please I'm afraid we're gonna spoil this
dress
[Music]
welcome to your home away from home
this dwelling was built by architect
Frederick Banner in 1955. if I had to be
stuck in a house it could do worse than
this
[Music]
do you think he's watching us oh
yeah
I remember reading that Banner was
obsessed with the occult His Wife
disappeared under mysterious
circumstances his young son went into
foster care oh
that's the address house 1960 Marion
Lane
is hello I must have gotten the days
mixed up we have a book till tomorrow
I'm Eldridge the owner
[Music]
I think I saw someone in this house I'm
worried just let me know you're okay
yeah
do you live here are you still
[Music]
I found some human information
my father committed multiple murders
[Music]
the spirit is able to escape death must
have been on the heart of watching
Eldritch through into his father
help me put an end to him
[Music]
vermita
[Music]
is
foreign
[Music]
Amira
[Music]
I can't believe you're moving this
summer we're always going to be friends
pick you up in time
[Music]
it's gonna be hot this weekend should we
do something
[Music]
it's over there this weird little
building where that girl was sacrificed
in a Satanic ritual let's go in come on
ABS one more Adventure
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I guess that's one way to put it dollars
of donuts it's demonic possession
exorcism
[Applause]
[Music]
what was that
[Music]
God damn we got ourselves a demon
[Music]
I Think We're Alone Now
oh my God
it doesn't seem to be anyone around
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
this Halloween you can't escape the
shark the terror of
werewolf by night tonight it is every
Hunter for themselves good luck I'll be
rotting for you
but one of you is a monster
masquerading as one of our own
can't wait to find out what breed of
evil you are
[Music]
[Applause]
please don't do this
jazz is coming for you
werewolf by night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]